tôt le pauvre ça vaille roos le pouls du
baiia oh non il n'a pas encore été
touché par les attendait du modernisme
des grues électrique par exemple fort
pratique me direz-vous bien sûr mais ici
risquerait d'enlever un cachet que nous
pouvons apprécier en ce moment clermont
mario claveau peintre brésilien
bahia s'opposent franchement et
farouchement à l'assaut des temps
modernes
telle une vieille dame sur du charme de
ces régimes heureuse elle reste ce
qu'elle est une cité du vieux brésil
portugais
un chapeau en banane touche porte sur la
tête
que ce soit dans le bassin du port ou
sur les quais qui l'entourent on croît
constamment assisté à des scènes du
brésil pittoresque de debré
l'enjeu n'est pas là chapeau celui là
c'est une corbeille plein cette fois
oui
les marchands aisée possède des baraques
les étals artistiquement des montagnes
de bananes d'orange de noix de coco ou
de piment rouge les petits vendeurs vous
offre à la sauvette presque des bouquets
de fleurs qui semble arranger pour des
demoiselles d'honneur sur bandes couleur
jupe plissée comme celle des tsiganes
ainsi vont les bayonnaises sentinelle de
bahia tout au fond le fort de sao
marcelo il surveille sans en avoir l'air
les abords de la ville connus entre
auckland en sorte c'est à lui que
s'adresse le mot de passe
et pour se distraire après le travail
les ouvriers du port les ouvriers des
plantations se réunissent pour danser là
comme payera danse extrêmement curieuse
et dont les origines très lointaines
remonte en angola deux instruments de
musique
un pan d irak est un tambourin et un
bimbo à instruments à cordes possédant
une caisse de résonance en l'occurrence
une demie calvasse une pièce de monnaie
anciennes touchant en évitant la corde
bassier vibrante au coup de baguette
d'un sont bizarres
elora planta airways joue semble-t-il
presque plus que dans des tentes
certains tout ceci dans la joie it à pau
anne sable fin pamiers le caporal mille
fois chantée par la plus belle voix du
brésil puisque d'orival qu'éminent est
né dans ce paradis pamiers qui repose
nous regardent et vivent les gens gaïdar
hausser leurs bateaux
rado de voile fait de plusieurs tronc de
balsa simplement réunis par des cordes
et au dessus desquels est attaché à un
siège quelconque ils sont appelés ces
bateaux légende ghaddar sur ses radeaux
primitif les hommes ce hasard fort loin
sur la mer et l'on raconte l'amusante
histoire d'un bateau américain qui
stoppe pas et voulu se porter au secours
d'une langue ada croyant que c'était une
épave sur laquelle se trouvaient des
naufragés il n'en était rien eu nous
ment
on rentre
de la pêche mais a su comme l'attestent
ses images
les jeunes cadets et ross ont de curieux
chapeau aux formes et aux couleurs
différentes et là bas aussi le premier
arrivé celui bien entendu qui vend le
plus de poissons
pénélope moderne inlassablement elle
brode s'en défaire il est vrai mais elle
aussi attend son mari un marin
les gens gallas sont baptisés si elle ne
l'était pas il semblerait qu'elle soit
incomplète
quatre hommes sur une jeune ghada son
parti de fortaleza et au réussi le
formidable exploit de terminer leur
voyage dans le sud du brésil à porto
allègre soit 2600 kilomètres plus loin
je lis n'est ce pas it happen un champ
la mer chaque jour on jette un immense
filet et des centaines de pêcheurs
stanton et des milliers de fois sur
quatre mais le même bien s'y prend le
regarder ces images
personnellement je le climat assez
extraordinaire un peu jeune mais bientôt
candidat à être lui aussi pêcheur doxa
russe être pêcheur doxa run est une
dynastie de père mon fils dont les
origines lointaines ont pris racine dans
la terre africaine
il tire les filets sans s'arrêter le
chantait rythmant leurs efforts dans un
extraordinaire ballet voyez-vous
centimètre par centimètre
il avance
même patience oui recule nous avons le
mouvement finira tout de même va ramener
sur la rive le filet avec ceux qui
comptent
chapeau un peu fatigué mais enfin cela
il faut attendre maintenant pour voir ce
qu'il va se produire
prévoyants sans doute doit pas avoir de
porte chez lui une corde autour du
chapeau ne sait jamais ça peut toujours
servir
voilà le fil et approche les
signalisations soit homogène et on lui
voit apparaître de plus en plus le filet
se resserre nous allons voir enfin ce
qu'il va sortir de la mer nous sommes
presque je crois ou si ému que les
pêcheurs mais ils ont puisqu'une fois du
poisson n'est plus porté par la mer et
il faut maintenant s'efforcer de
maintenir le filet en surface tout en
essayant de ne pas lâcher prise
c'est aux éclaireurs un scandale
fouettés par les vagues
submergée même par les vagues regarder
les travailler une grande habitude
nécessaire certainement sur sa france
qui seraient rapidement essoufflé et
jours 7 et 1 cm par son revenu
voilà le filet arrive la prise par est
excellente l'eau bouillonne
elle rougit légèrement et maintenant
c'est l'instant crucial est une fausse
manoeuvre peut faire que tout est perdu
pour ne rien vous cacher c'est leur
première pêche du printemps
ce qu'on attend qu'elle soit 20 leur
portera chance pour la néo mais oui
regardez ce sont des bunny poisson ferme
il se rapproche du maquereau de nos
côtes
vous avez vu comme ils se font aider par
le vague
voilà l'événement le ramassage va
commencer ainsi qu'une criage c'est une
pêche miraculeuse les dieux est exaucé
leurs prières
alors demain il y aura d'autres
fonctions
de dand à 300 dessins
mario bédard 70
yonan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
samba sport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de marcel
easy charte et de solange péters